artists and creators throughout history
have spoken of inspiration practically
from the cradle
a tendency toward writing or sculpture
or music from before they could speak
charming obey chinoy is not one of those
artists
i was 21 i never studied film i've
studied economics and
government so i literally typed into
this search bar
visual journalism and the word
documentary films popped up and i was
like
that's it i'm going to be a documentary
filmmaker
her films have won academy awards emmys
and numerous other honors
she's become one of the most influential
advocates for human rights around the
world
focusing specifically on the plight of
women in her home country of pakistan
and beyond i spoke with charmaine about
her insatiable desire to speak truth to
power
and the power that comes from listening
closely to those whose stories need to
be told
women are realizing that they want a say
in their lives that they want to say in
how the government treats them
that they want a say in having more
space in the public sphere
[Music]
men are afraid
tell me about growing up your growing up
years because
from everything that i've read and heard
about you it's so formative your family
is so
formative from a very young age
something was instilled in you i grew up
in
karachi pakistan and you know i'm the
eldest of six children
five of them girls i grew up in a family
that
wanted uh the daughters to have an
education we were free to speak our
minds
and that was very encouraging
from a very young age i realized that i
had grown up
on the side of the tracks where i was
very lucky
and i remember one particular instance
when i was about 10 years old and i was
driving going to school and my car had
stopped at a traffic light
and i remember looking out of the window
and i saw a young girl
she was about 10 years old and you know
she was barefoot and
she had her hand pressed out and her
nose was glued to
the window screen and she was begging i
remember thinking why is she not in
school
and i always had these questions you
know like why is this not happening why
is that not happening
pakistan is a society which frowns upon
questions that are probing you know
you're supposed to accept the status quo
this is just the way it is don't talk
about this
it'll bring shame and so i was that
annoying kid
in class who would put up the hand all
the time and ask those difficult
questions
and at home i did that as well and my
mother was raising five children was
like
you need to ask someone else these
questions
and she encouraged me to write and i
became
a writer when i was about 14 years old
and i think i've never looked back
charmaine's innate drive to ask
questions and seek the answers led her
to the united states
where she pursued her higher education
at smith college that was despite her
family's initial reluctance
although she studied economics and
political science her experience at
smith
ultimately led her down a different path
you know when i was on campus
i held a lot of sit-ins i was a very
i was involved in student government i
was junior junior class president
i was very politically active and
it gave me an opportunity to meet people
from around the world
women who came from africa and asia
and the united states who if you think
would have had different experiences but
let me tell you
women around the world share a lot in
common it doesn't matter
where they come from there is an
inherent bias against women
that exists in almost every society
in the world whether it's in the north
or the east or the south or the west
and i think that was a transformative
period for me
as a individual because right out of
smith
i decided to take up documentary
filmmaking and switch my careers right
so on that note you give me a great
opening to talk about
what i think is a pivotal moment and i
think you'll agree and and i got a
chance to catch up with with your
colleague and friend trish
and she talked about meeting you for the
first time and a pivotal
moment that that you have with uh with a
very well-known news organization here
in the united states
when we met it was in a coffee shop and
um
we it was like realizing that we shared
the same goal
of finding voices that weren't being
heard
giving them a voice giving them a light
and we were young at the time
and we didn't have connections and
charming
like marched into the new york times
office and said you know i have a story
and i want to make a film
and um you know it was kind of an
outlandish thing to do in your early 20s
and she was able to do it and she went
and she made films on the front lines of
a lot of war zones in the middle east
and came back and delivered these
stories of from people who were
suffering from injustice and whose
voices weren't being heard and they made
it to new york times and reached an
international audience
so that's a big moment obviously yes it
was you know i was 21 years old and i
was writing for these newspapers and 9
11 had happened
and i would watch the nightly news and i
would see all these people catapulting
into south asia and into afghanistan and
pakistan and
with very little understanding of what
what the politics of the region were and
what was happening and i thought to
myself
i can tell stories from that part of the
world to this part of the world
and then i wrote up this proposal for my
first film i wanted to do a film about
the impact of the war in afghanistan on
the youngest victims of the war
which were the children of afghanistan
and i sent it off to about
i mean 80 organizations in the united
states every
production house i could find one day
online i found
the uh email address of the president of
the then new york times television and i
emailed him and
you know 15 minutes later he responded
and i bought my first suit and
got on an amtrak train and went to new
york and i pitched it to the editorial
board of the new york times and
they funded my first film my first few
[Music]
films
[Music]
spent her first 15 films in front of the
camera amplifying powerful stories
through her own experience and with her
own voice
by 2011 she decided to put the focus
squarely on the lives and struggles of
her subjects
that led to her breakthrough film saving
face about women in pakistan who've been
the victims of acid attacks
the film earned her an academy award the
first ever won by a pakistani
to all the women in pakistan who are
working for change don't give up on your
dreams
this is for you
[Applause]
i immerse myself in a world where
um so many women literally were
disfigured
simply because they were brave enough to
say
no no to uh violence
when acid is thrown on your face your
entire face
carries that mark forever when you wake
up in the morning and you see your face
in the mirror you're reminded
of that incident and telling this story
was so important because
the legislation in pakistan was so weak
around asset violence at that time that
both daniel and i felt
that this was a story we needed to tell
we needed to impact legislation
and impact the way people saw
acid violence in the country
i think the moment for me in this film
was when zakia
who is a woman who had had acetone on
her face by her
husband because she wanted a divorce
i remember walking in to film her one
morning
and you know half of zakia's face was
gone
it had been disfigured and she was
peeling apples for her daughter
and she was smiling and they were
telling jokes to each other about
cats and kittens and they were both
laughing and in that mother daughter
moment i realized that
these are some of the bravest women that
i have known
because through this ordeal they have
laughed
and joked and not forgotten that they
are after all
mothers and human beings and that's why
that story
really changed the way i saw the
strength of a woman
and so that clearly vaults you to a new
level in in your career you
you become much better known globally
and and also in your own country where
obviously you're well known at that
point but this is a new
new level and and things start to
accelerate for you
does it become harder or easier as you
gain more notoriety
pakistan does not take too well to
having a woman who has a voice
and who's not afraid to use her
and i think that when i won my first
academy award
people suddenly realized that i had a
voice and
um there were many who wanted to silence
it because i was taking
up issues that they didn't want taken up
especially
um not on the global level and um
you know i would wake up some mornings
and i would read social media
and i would learn some things about
myself i didn't even know were true
um and so you know um there were massive
campaigns that were started to discredit
me
but you know none of it can stick
because all i'm doing
is telling stories that are
real stories that need to be told
it's interesting that we're talking
about this because i want to bring in
uh another interview about you
to have you watch with your friend
marvie
marvie mazzer is a prominent architect
based in karachi pakistan
she's bonded with charmin over the
important role of women in pakistani
society
i think pakistan is is is so
open to ideas right now on every
different platform from
artists community from a bureaucratic
level i feel they're giving
they're giving they're giving that space
to women and and generally to new ideas
i feel uh pakistan has a lot of
potential in giving that space to others
it makes its mistakes it has its own
teething issues
but that's where uh people like shirmeen
bring in a lot of perspective
uh working with the government working
with local
diaspora and then bringing and knitting
it together so i feel
that way all of us are have the same
vision
of making making pakistan on a platform
where
it recognizes such new ideas and new
ventures
so she seemed when i spoke with her very
optimistic i think that comes through in
that comment do you share that
i do i share the optimism and i'll tell
you this
that the internet has changed pakistan
there is a free flowing of ideas
if you would ask me in my 20s would have
worked with the government i would have
said never
but i do work with the government in
pakistan on projects
uh a lot um i work currently i'm working
with the ministry of human rights with
the ministry of law and justice
but i will also say this that
um it is a country where you have to
dance
where you have to walk the fine line
where
you have to think about
the projects that you're working on and
the personal repercussions
those would have on you and so i have
learned
to navigate those worlds and
when you live in pakistan i think you're
sort of born with that navigation skills
[Music]
as charmaine's influences expanded so
has her portfolio
her 2016 short documentary a girl in the
river about honor killings of pakistani
women
won her a second oscar the first time
anyone had won
twice in the category this is what
happens when determined women
get together the film's international
recognition helped
inspire legislation in pakistan that
made honor killings illegal
that closed a loophole that had
previously allowed the practice to go
unpunished my film deals with
forgiveness
and how the law is manipulated and now
they're going to change that
she's also taken on subject matter far
beyond her home country's borders
calling out what she sees as
exploitation in american college
athletics
in the documentary student athlete she's
also produced a range of animated films
to broaden her audience
in addition to thinking about what to
make she's also thinking about who's
making it
and who's watching the finished product
about four years ago
i thought about my body of work i've
created so many films um
who's watched them you know of course i
have a global audience but locally
who's been able to watch them the ones
that are on the internet are still
accessible
to the ones who have access to internet
and so i built a mobile cinema
that goes from village to village town
to town showcasing not just my films
but also films of other filmmakers and
the ideas
was that we would take these films into
the heartland
into the towns and villages where men
and women and children together
could watch films and have discussions
afterwards
and our films range from for women how
to inherit property or
how to get a divorce or if they're
battered you know which is the shelter
they can go to
those are informational films i feel
like the choices i'm making
um have a lot to do with ensuring that
the next generation
in my country has the opportunities that
i did
by exposing them to to thoughts and
ideas
and competing world views you said
something that that i want to
to get you to talk a little bit more
about which is men watching your films
you know globally i feel like men
of all nationalities are reckoning with
our history as a as a sex
our history as it relates to women
how has your relationship with the the
male population
as it were if you can generalize changed
there are men
in pakistan who abort me
who cannot stand me who think that
i should be silenced
and that's because they're afraid
that women like myself will take back
power
that we will no longer be
seeking permission that we will just
grab it
and at the same time i have a lot of men
who come up to me
at airports who come up to me at public
spaces and say
i want my daughter to be just like you
i want her to be free i want her to be
able to speak her mind
so as pakistan is a society that is
changing there will be people who will
love me and my work and there will be
people
who will dislike me and my work but i
choose to hear the voices that cheer me
on to the finish line
and not the ones that want me to be
silenced
you know it strikes me as you're
speaking that you know going back to
this
this idea of balance and and in an
interview you gave
you you talked about your your desire
and your need to
provoke anger sometimes because anger
leads to to action
and yet at the same time it feels like
there's a tone through so much of your
work that is about hope
and encouragement and and i do wonder
how you strike that balance and and how
you go about doing that daily how you go
about doing that
as you choose projects and and make
films
i think that anger is a really important
emotion
because when you're angry then you're
moved to
discuss issues you're moved to push
legislation through
your move to ensure that that injustice
does not happen
to anyone else but i think it's equally
important
in the world that we live in today in a
24-hour news cycle
to have hope because if you don't have
hope
then you don't have a desire to create
change
and so it's important for me to show the
wins as much as it is important for me
to show the losses
and i think it was a few years ago i
decided that i no longer wanted to talk
about
issues i wanted to talk about the
champions
who were creating change
who were working on those issues we
understand that that
that issue is enormous we understand
that it'll probably
outlive her lifetime but that someone is
working
on that and that gives us hope that
you're chipping away at something
day by day by day
you